hello and welcome to this video good
white again lots of whites there yeah
no not even not statistically that's not
true like sure just felt like said the
third white in a row no okay I just have
a wrong impression day I'm sorry just I
was just completely expecting to have
black so he's a little ski Wow
eight thousand games eight thousand is a
lot so everything fine I got the blitz
number right that's good scotch four
nights one of the main pillars of the e4
repertoire that I've published a while
ago so what do we do here clay for us
for later maybe very solid opening
cannot expect something dramatic to
happen but I have a huge advantage away
actually didn't want to do that was
thinking night a for b3 was a bit early
okay
why is he going to beat you it would be
odd it's going back okay and that you
can definitely do sorry if my voice is
irritating I need a little bit of water
should see how he's playing this like
instant moves the whole time not unhappy
with them putting more pawns on light
squares the bishop sitting on d7 it's
not a huge problem or anything but g6
it's not a move that helps black a bit
of a bit of a non move okay what is this
doing I have no clue going to c3 he
wants to go see five maybe no come on
I know do you do it you take back when
it's kind of silly if it declines it's
okay but not going to do it okay it's
okay now it's it's a mouse club and it's
fair but it's just like it so response
the video yeah it's okay I'm not not
angry or anything it's very silly of
course because why it was already I was
already very comfortable him yeah I of
course wanted to take I'm not quite sure
how this happened
it's a bit audience
somehow I made this move well I wanted
to take and then f3 and then black goes
back somewhere I got to go to e3
actually okay okay
when c3 is more precise you know I'm
already very happy because I'm sitting
here with a nice night against a pretty
bad Bishop this is an ending where I
would have tortured him forever and
probably man oh you never know maybe he
defends it but it's going to be a long
road and it's going to be pretty awful
yeah I don't know I'm going to upload
this field because this is pretty
instructive that this is in fact pretty
comfortable I shouldn't go here actually
because he's got this one mm that is not
not ideal but after c3 this is very nice
and you can play this on forever and
black would have no fun at all he
basically did everything that you can do
here to give me an edge put everything
on light squares and so on so that's a
bit bit of a shame that i blundered that
i blundered to the roof with the mouse
anyway thanks a lot for watching guys
bye bye